this video is sponsored by nordvpn
[Music]
this right here is one of my all-time
favorite moments in one piece the energy
the emotions and the impact it carries
are simply fantastic however i think it
takes a
quite unique place in the series because
while most of the other iconic moments
in one piece
are based on positive empowering or
sentimental scenes when luffy walks up
to charlos to punch him in the face
the strong emotion this moment carries
is one of burning rage and anger
this shot works so incredibly well
because it scratches the itch that
chapter 502
and episode 396 of one piece
have built up to that point and the
feeling of
helplessness injustice and despair
that not only the characters but also
the audience experience is something
that is
quite unique in oda's story
it is in this chapter i believe that oda
fully pulls aside the colorful shonen
curtain with which he covers the story
and exposes the true dark dystopia of
the story world
that we otherwise only get small
glimpses at
[Music]
and so in today's video i want to
discuss with you
why i believe that 502 is the darkest
chapter of the entire story so far with
an almost shakespearean level of tragedy
and why it makes luffy's punch one of
the
best scenes in the story oh yeah and if
you haven't already
make sure to subscribe to the channel
we're actually getting really damn close
to hitting 100k
the scene takes place in the first half
of the zabaori archipelago arc
that until today is one of my favorite
arcs
overall the mermaid kami has been
kidnapped by human traffickers to be
solved at a slave auction
and the straw hats have entered the
auction hall planning to use the 200
million barry of treasure they have
to buy her free without causing any
major commotion
next to the general high society of the
one piece world dressed in glamorous
clothes
three celestial dragons have joined the
auction as well
and so have used this kit and trafalgar
law
before their eyes a young dancing girl
is being sold for 7.2 million berries
meanwhile a very frustrated looking
charlos who is desperate to buy a
mermaid to be chased around in his
piranha tank
kicks another one of his slaves
the next candidate is a former renowned
pirate captain
that is now being sold off like cattle
before
anyone in the audience can start bidding
however his mouth suddenly starts
filling with blood
and he collapses on the floor as it
turns out he has
bitten off his tongue to kill himself
rather than become a slave next up is
finally kami who like all the other
slaves wears a collar
that will explode should anyone try to
remove it
the crew seems pretty confident to get
her however
upon seeing the mermaid charlos
immediately bids
500 million berries and seals the deal
for her
to the shock of everyone else in the
room the now
terrified kami tries to scream out to
hodgson
but her cries can't reach through the
thick walls of her tank
and just when kit decides to leave upon
seeing all this
luffy and zorro finally reach the hall
as well in their typical fashion
by smashing straight through the roof
upon seeing kami luffy starts towards
the tank
but is stopped by hodgson who
accidentally reveals all of his arms
and thus him being a fishman this
immediately creates panic within the
auction hall as the fishermen are not
only strongly discriminated against here
but are actually banned from even
setting foot on the islands
and so for the very first time the crew
gets to witness the true
level of discrimination against their
race first hand
the turmoil stops as suddenly as it has
started when the room is suddenly
pierced by gunfire
as luffy turns around he sees hodgson
falling over shot by none other than the
celestial dragon charlos
who's excitedly celebrating his kill
in this moment luffy's entire demeanor
changes while the onlookers are relieved
that the dangerous and deceased riddled
monster has been killed
he slowly starts walking towards the
tendrio beto
the heavily wounded hotjohn tries to
stop him blaming himself for what has
happened
and apologizing that he could not make
up for what he had done to
nami and her village fully redeeming his
character in this moment
this however just seems to harden
luffy's resolve
unstoppable he closes in on charlos
who fails to shoot him and luffy punches
him in the face
so hard that he leaves a permanent
imprint of his fist on his face
[Applause]
and speaking of imprints i'd like to
talk for a moment about the sponsor of
today's video
nordvpn while luffy definitely left an
imprint on charlos
i don't recommend doing so yourself when
it comes to your activity online
if you follow this channel for a while
you'll probably know that i rarely do
sponsorships
since i only want to work with companies
that i'm really comfortable with and can
recommend myself
i've been using nordvpn myself the past
two years
mostly to unlock japanese netflix to
watch the first season of terrace house
for example
and i'm also using it to watch anime
that are not available in germany
like one piece occasionally a server
might not work perfectly but with over 5
000 fast servers in over 59 countries
and unlimited bandwidth it's super easy
to just choose a new one
hit refresh and you're good to go as a
member of the fox gang you can now get
68 of nordvpn for 3.71
a month plus an entire additional month
for free
at nordvpn.com o'hara
the link is in the description below now
something that i can't put in the
description below
is describe how much i love this scene
i mean what a roller coaster of a
chapter
so much negativity cruelty and
immorality
building up in just 16 pages
emotional storytelling at its best i
think you will probably
already have a pretty good idea what
makes this chapter
so incredibly dark for me even though no
one dies
no one is betrayed and nothing is lost
i think kit summarizes it pretty good in
this panel here
where he fittingly describes the auction
house as a miniature of the world
what does he mean by that well you see
saba odi is the first arc that we
actually meet the world nobles
and see their rule and tyranny in action
in the world of one piece they stand on
top of the food chain
they are a tiny group of people that
hold most of the wealth and power of the
world
anything that they want they get laws
don't apply to them
they're made to actually make their
lives better
they have complete control of the world
governments
and if a civilian so much as crosses
paths with them
without bowing down they will be shot
and killed at the spot
they literally see themselves as the
gods of the one-piece worlds
and they certainly behave and live that
way
and so when kid says that the slave
auction is like the world in miniature
it tells us an awful lot about the state
of the world itself
as will be confirmed later on in the
story it means that even
on a large scale the celestial dragons
simply do what they want
with a disregard for human life morality
and humanity
they dominate everything and everyone
and no one is able to lift so much as a
finger against them
luffy's friend kami suddenly is nothing
more than a product that is sold to the
highest bidder
to amuse his twisted fantasies so
the scene gives us a first major glimpse
at
who the world government truly
represents and what the true cruelty of
the one piece world really looks like
and just as kid stated the human auction
house
is a wonderful narrative symbol for all
of that
even though it's in the center of unjust
and inhuman slave trade
the marines euphemistically refer to it
as the public employment security office
sadly i probably don't have to tell you
that referring to slave work as
employment
has happened plenty of times throughout
real history as well in an attempt to
soften
and normalize the exploitation of human
beings
it's not a mere sign of corruption
within the marines
but they literally have no other choice
but to look the other way as they
directly obey the celestial dragon's
rule
now what makes the symbolism of the
auction house even more
fitting however is the fact that it was
owned by none other
than don quixot flamingo the leader of
the underworld
powerful warlord and one of the cruelest
antagonists in the story
i think it truly says nothing good about
the world if it resembles something run
by doflamingo
whose own country that can in many ways
also be seen as a miniature of the world
was one of the darkest and most corrupt
places that the straw hats have visited
doflamingo being a former celestial
dragon himself is of course
just a cherry on top them as he himself
has suffered his entire life under the
system of the world nobles
[Music]
and so thematically this darkest of all
chapters
fits more than perfectly into the
arguably darkest arc of the series so
far
all this stuff with nobles people being
bought and sold and walked around with
collars
people being sold like items in an
auction house
hachi and kami having to hide themselves
due to long-standing racism
that's still heavily ingrained in the
people of the world
all that is only the first part of the
actual arc
it leaves a quite disturbing and
uncomfortable feel on his readers
as we were mostly used to a more
adventure based storyline
with smaller villains in between yet
here the
entire political system of the world is
revealed to be twisted and broken
throughout
designed for the pleasure of a selected
view and
exploiting the rest kit who i think got
a wonderful introduction in this arc
has a fantastic and incredibly
underrated speech about all this i think
[Music]
i think this really hits it on the head
as kid states correctly here many
pirates like himself
have no doubt done horrendous things
however they're not a unified group like
the world government is
and it was the terror injustice and
poverty of the current system
that led to the high level of piracy in
the world in the first place
luffy's backstory for instance being a
great example of this
and so i would argue that oda tries to
make clear in this chapter
that the world government is overall the
greater evil
compared to the pirates which is also
why true change
has come by the hands of pirates such as
roger or luffy
so let's finally talk about that punch
that i think we
all immensely enjoyed seeing
it's especially nicely done in the anime
i think
whether change from black to white
luffy's
wok charlotte's dropping face as well as
the unique sound design really bring the
scene to life
and multiply its impacts based on
everything we have discussed so far i
think it's very easy to see
what makes luffy's moment of pure anger
so cathartic to see luffy is the only
one who dares to actually stand up to
the true
injustice and tyranny of the worlds who
actually shows
charlos that you can't just do whatever
to people and that actions
actually should have consequences
something that
no admiral no yonko and no one else
has there to do in that sense when luffy
punches
charlos and bursts the bubble that is
supposed to keep him
from breathing the same air as the
common people luffy
also bursts his metaphoric bubble of
divine and
unlimited power once again the d
as the natural enemy of the gods
luffy committing the ultimate sin and
declaring war on the gods
themselves thus what makes this scene
so special is that it's a moral and
emotional island of
light in a sea of darkness that is the
saba of the archipelago arc
luffy is giving us here this moment of
much needed justice and
courage that allows us to hope for the
world to truly change for the better
with him
which is exactly what so many
other people see in him when the pirate
captain bites off his tongue early in
the chapter to escape slavery
sanji in a wonderful moment for his
character comments this
in the end it's all about freedom and
his captain in the scene is
once again proving that he is the freest
of them all
free to actually do the right thing and
stand up to the worlds
[Music]
now what ultimately makes this moment
even better for me however from a
storytelling perspective
is how in typical shakespearean fashion
it is the catalyst for even more tragedy
to happen
luffy bravely punching charlos leads to
the eviction of a buster call
during which kizaru and shuten maru
completely overwhelmed the crew as well
as all of the other supernova
and in the end luffy and us readers had
to witness how one by one
each of the straw hats disappears by the
hands of kuma
resulting in maybe the most shocking
moments
of the entire story the straw hat's
complete defeat
all set up by this moment right here
this my friends i think is storytelling
and tragic writing
at its peak and speaking of tragic
writing at its peak
in the next video i want to talk about
one of the most tragic and misunderstood
moments
after the timeskip
and so we'll be looking at that in the
next video
thanks guys peace